thank you
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story Junior doctors to walk
house in a row over pay in what is
likely to be the most disruptive NHS
strike in history because of the strike
he says the junior doctors who have got
no theaters and we've got no staff
a show of strength from Ira supporters
on the 25th anniversary of the Good
Friday agreement ahead of the arrival of
the U.S president
zero regrets securest armor defends
controversial labor adverts attacking
the Prime Minister also tonight
the mother of two British Israeli
sisters shot dead in the occupied West
Bank dies in hospital
President Biden says he plans to run for
re-election in 2024 but it's not
official yet
plus York City Center is among seven
British historic sites aiming for world
heritage status
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in our press
preview from 10 30.
[Music]
hello there a very good evening Junior
doctors are due to go on strike within
hours in what's expected to be the most
disruptive walkouts in the history of
the NHS as many as 300 000 operations
could be canceled and NHS England says
it will be forced to prioritize
emergency and Urgent Care during the
four days of strike action
well doctors are calling for 35 pay rise
to compensate for what they say is 15
years of below inflation wage increases
it's estimated 28 000 staff are off
during the last walkout by Junior
doctors back in March disrupting 175
000 Hospital appointments in England now
the chief executive of the NHS
Confederation believes as many as 350
000 appointments and operations could be
canceled during this next wave of
industrial action the skies Tom
Parmenter reports
it's in Malcolm's kitchen where this
strike really hits home
how much pain is she in with the
shoulder
crying pain I mean she she sits there
and cries with it you know his wife
Maureen needs treatment for fluid on the
brain but she also needs shoulder
surgery that operation was due to
finally happen this month unfortunately
says we wanted to cancel
yeah I said why because it's customer
strike he says the junior doctor says
we've got no theaters and we've got no
staff she spends much of the day in bed
and Malcolm just keeps topping up the
painkillers which are becoming less and
less effective the NHS hospitals in
their part of Lincolnshire acknowledge
this week will be difficult but say
critical services will keep running it
is the timing of this strike that makes
it so disruptive coming in right after
the long Easter bank holiday weekend and
Junior doctors are so often the ones who
hold it all together when services are
stretched
four days without them means senior
colleagues consultants and other NHS
staff stepping in across England
the contingency plans here at West
Middlesex Hospital in West London are
fairly typical it cannot be business as
usual we'll be prioritizing emergency
surgery we'll be prioritizing Cancer
Care care for children intensive care
patients but there will be patients who
will have their care postponed which
will be very frustrating for patients up
and down the country and there will be a
period where we will have to work
exceptionally hard to try and meet that
backlog of patients which we know exists
at even at this point without the strike
like nurses and ambulance workers Junior
doctors want better pay too
they say the service they provide is in
crisis and that they've had 15 years of
below inflation pay increases but the
health secretary says their request for
a 35 pay rise is unrealistic
with no breakthrough the Health Service
in England is once again asking for the
Public's help our main message to the
public this evening is use the NHS
sensibly if you've got a
life-threatening emergency ring 999 but
otherwise make good use of your local
pharmacy your local general practitioner
and the 111 online service because our
hospitals will be under significant
amounts of pressure during the course of
the rest of this week until there's a
settlement patience and their carers all
just muddle through in pain and often
alone
it's not the care anyone wants to
provide
Tom Parmenter Sky News Lincolnshire
and let's take a look at which other
strikes are coming up in the next few
days passport office star far into the
second week of a five-week walkout as
we've just been hearing Junior doctors
taking industrial action tomorrow
morning for four days until Saturday at
7 00 A.M
more than 130 000 civil servants will
strike on April the 28th including
border force staff driving examiners in
the UK will stage walkouts in different
regions over eight dates in April and
teachers from the National Education
Union are holding two more days of
walkouts on April the 27th and again on
May the second full coverage of course
here on Sky News
on the 25th anniversary of the signing
of the Good Friday agreement police in
Northern Ireland say petrol bombs have
been thrown at their offices at a parade
in Derry the event was held by dissident
Republicans who are opposed to the
agreement it comes just hours ahead of
President Biden's arrival in Northern
Ireland our senior Island correspondent
David Blevins reports now from
Londonderry
the past casts a long shadow in Northern
Ireland
these Irish Republicans weren't cheering
The Good Friday agreement but Marching
In opposition to it and their refusal to
condemn the use of violence leads to the
inevitable
youths attacking police in Londonderry
this is exactly the tactic security
Chiefs had feared that young people
would be incited to engage in civil
disorder to attract officers into this
area where they become vulnerable to
terrorist attack
it was a sporadic incident but the
threat of something more serious remains
with dissident Republicans publicly
encouraging armed conflict in pursuit of
Irish Unity
so long as you continue to oppress us
you will meet with the inescapable
consequences
historically oppression breed resistance
so I quote more a drum it isn't enough
to shape up the ARA the important thing
is to join
but former Shin fan leader Jerry Adams
who persuaded the provisional Ira to
call a ceasefire says the Good Friday
agreement gave armed groups an
alternative we knew the agreement wasn't
the end the agreement was the beginning
of a new Journey
uh but but at least we had a mechanism
for people to have their say uh which
then allowed us to argue that there was
that there was no need for armed actions
or no need for violence that this was
the the way to go forward
there will be a major Security operation
for President Biden's visit the lack of
a power sharing government at Stormont
contributing to a dangerous political
vacuum here 25 years ago the commitment
was from the parties to resolve
differences through Democratic and
peaceful means and that's the only
alternative to the use of political
violence and this is why in the face of
the apparent rise in the in the
Terror threat that the institutions
remain fundamentally important and that
means of democratic expression remains
just as important today as as ever
before
if Rishi sunak needs reminding that
pieces on finished business it's the
Sinister image of masked men and women
glorifying terrorism with an illegal
parade David Blevins Sky News in Derry
well tensions around the anniversary of
the agreement come as President Biden
prepares to visit both sides of the
Irish Border visiting both capitals as
well as two of his ancestral homes
President Biden will land in Belfast on
Air Force One tomorrow night and on
Wednesday he'll give a speech at Ulster
University's newly opened Belfast campus
and meet norish political leaders as
well as the Prime Minister Rishi sunak
who is also visiting to Mark the
anniversary of the Good Friday agreement
the president will then fly to Dublin
he's also expected to visit Dundalk and
carlingford in County louth from where
his great great grandfather emigrated to
the U.S in the 1840s and on Thursday
he'll become the fourth American
president to address the Irish
Parliament addressing both houses he's
also expected to meet the Irish Prime
Minister Lee of Radka and the Irish
President Michael D Higgins while in
Dublin and then on Friday President
Biden will visit County mayor where
he'll give a public address outside to
murdax Cathedral in Ballina from where
another of the president's
great-great-grandfathers emigrated and
there will be continuing coverage of
calls throughout the day and indeed the
week here on Skype news
labor has defended its controversial
advertisement campaign targeting the
Prime Minister over the conservatives
record on Law and Order which has been
widely criticized including by labor
politicians sakistan said he makes zero
apologies for the adverts one of which
accused Wishy sunak of not wanting to
see child sex abusers go to prison our
political correspondent Rob Powell has
more
Dudley North in the West Midlands labor
held until 2019 secure stama's path to
power runs straight through
constituencies like these they should go
to prison Dennis has voted for both main
parties while Sue has always gone Tory
what do they make of Labor's new and
aggressive campaigning style I don't
agree that's hard hitting I think that's
personal
and that is unfair I think they're all
they're all soft on chroma todayola he
can get away with any of these days over
here let's face it they all do it don't
they they all dish the dirt and they all
try and you know other property to each
other and it's futile there's no need
for it people is not stupid they'll vote
for who they want so kirst armor today
backed these ads which were made
in-house at Labor writing in the mail
that he stood by every word no matter
how squeamish it made some feel one
thing can be said over the last few days
at least we're starting to debate the
criminal justice system which for far
too long I think you know we have been
avoiding looking at but we need to look
at hard and you know as Kiera said you
know he's dedicated his life to ensuring
that the criminal justice system works
but not everyone is happy veteran labor
MP Diane Abbott today attacked her
party's own campaign coordinator and
suggested one ad even had racial
overtones
this is a departure in style for secure
starmer and while the campaign has
gained publicity it's also ruffled
feathers with concern further up the
party hierarchy as well as on the back
benches a look online shows several
members of The Shadow cabinet haven't
even shared these new attack ads on
their own Twitter feed
especially very nice to see a flurry of
activity from Rishi sunak in recent
weeks has seen some polls indicate the
Tories eating into Labor's lead but the
prime minister is still more popular
than his party and that could be the
reason for this new aggressive labor
campaign what the local party seem to be
trying to do is making sure that the
conservative party is not dragged up to
Rishi sunax level it's an ill-advised
tactic because you're concentrating on
somebody who the polls show actually the
public has a reasonably positive view of
the Tories today accuse secure starmer
of being a lefty lawyer on the side of
terrorists and pedophiles the long arm
of the law are high priority as many
wonder whether this political debate is
reaching a new low
let's bring in Rob in he's in
Westminster for us so can we expect more
of these attack ads from labor Rob while
the Prime Minister concentrates on
events in Northern Ireland yeah those
behind this new aggressive strategy from
labor seem pretty thrilled with the last
few days One Source saying this evening
that it was mission accomplished that
they managed to dominate the news agenda
and open up a debate about the Tories uh
record and on crime I think we should
expect more of this in the near future
with labor potentially shifting Focus
onto the cost of living and trying to
link Rishi sunax Premiership to that of
his predecessor Liz truss and some of
the economic chaos that followed her
around during her time in Downey street
that may be a hard sell though given
that last summer Rishi sunak spent most
of that leadership campaign trashing Liz
truss's approach to the economy but as
that back and forth continues here in
Westminster Rishi sunak will turn his
attention to Northern Ireland he will be
in Belfast tomorrow evening meeting Joe
Biden off Air Force One but the stage
the political stage isn't really fully
set as Rishi sunak would have liked in
Belfast for this moment I think in an
Ideal World he would have wanted that
evolved institutions to be back up and
running in Belfast they are not the dup
are still boycotting the assembly and
the executive because of the brexit deal
today Rishi sunak once again called for
Stormont to get back up and running and
also praised those that signed the Good
Friday agreement 25 years ago singling
out their leadership and their
compromise I think you can expect more
of those types of sentiments in the days
ahead as prominent leaders try and Link
the achievements of the past to the
challenges of the present
Rob in Westminster thank you
to the States now and alone gum and
identified by the police's 23 year old
Connor sturgeon has killed four people
and injured nine others including a
police officer in a mass shooting in
Kentucky police arrived as gunshots were
ringing out inside the Old National Bank
in downtown Louisville around 8 30 a.m
local time offices exchanged fire with
the shooter who also died in the
incident
a very close friend that didn't make it
today
and I have another close friend who
didn't either and one who's at the
hospital
but I hope is is going to make it
through
so when we talk about praying I hope
people will
for those that we
are hoping can make it through the
surgeries that they're going through
and then we've got to do what we have
done these last three years after
everything we've got to wrap our arms
around these families
and everybody who needs it don't be
afraid to get some help
staying in the U.S President Biden has
appeared to confirm that he will run for
re-election in 2024 Mr Biden who is 80
years old told a reporter that he plans
on running but wasn't prepared to
officially announce it yes iOS
correspondent Mark stone is in
Washington for us this evening so Mark
he's hinted in the past hasn't he that
he's going to stand is it now definite
it looks that way at an election
incidentally at which gun violence as
you've just been discussing will I think
be one key thread that balance between
the right the constitutional rights to
bear arms and uh the extraordinary
levels of gun violence that they see
that are being seen right across the
United States but on the election yes he
has hinted once again as he has done
before that he intends to stand he is
looking I think his team are looking for
the right moment to be able to make that
formal announcement and then to ride on
the momentum that they think will come
from that announcement he was speaking
to a reporter at the annual Easter egg
roll and Easter egg hunt that takes
place at the White House every year the
reporter tried to get a bit out of him
on that point about whether he'll run
have a listen
wondering uh Mr President uh will you be
taking part in the Easter egg rolls
after planning on after 2024. I plan on
at least three to four more race at
least three or four months maybe maybe
five maybe five maybe six okay are you
saying that uh you would be taking part
in our upcoming election
because you know the guy who pushed him
out come on help your brother out make
sure I plan on running out we're not
concerned
look I think the the point is that it's
looking increasingly likely that the
Republican Party candidate will believe
it or not uh be Donald Trump and Joe
Biden knows that he beat Donald Trump
last time around his approval rating at
the moment is not great it's below water
it's about 38 39
but he does believe he has the ability
to beat Donald Trump again which is why
he and indeed his wife who he says is
his closest Council believe that he
should run again that formal
announcement though we don't know quite
yet when that will come and the big
thing the big concern about um Joe Biden
is frankly his age he would be 82 at the
point at which he was re-elected if he
was lucky to be and at the end of that
second term he'd be 86 years old he is a
man that is not getting any younger it
is an attack point for the Republicans
for the Democrats his age is certainly a
point of concern
okay Marky in Washington thank you
the mother of two British Israeli
sisters who were killed last week in a
shooting attack in the West Bank has
died the death of Lucy D comes a day
after the funeral of her daughter's 15
year old Rina and 20 year old Maya their
car was fired on while they were
traveling in the West Bank to go on a
family holiday earlier today her husband
spoke about coming to terms with the
loss of his family I called Lucy no
answer
I called Maya no answer
I called Rina
no answer
then I saw a missed call from Maya at 10
52.
I hadn't noticed it ring I hadn't picked
up the phone
the feeling that she called me during
the attack and I wasn't able to speak to
her will come back and haunt me for a
while a family of seven is now a family
of four
meanwhile a Palestinian teenager has
been killed in a raid by the Israeli
military in the West Bank 15 year old
Muhammad balhan died after sustaining
gunshot wounds in an operation to
apprehend Palestinians suspected of
attacks against Israelis in a statement
the country's military said soldiers
engaged the suspects in response to
being open fired on
the Dalai Lama has apologized for an
interaction with a young boy caught on
video in the recording the spiritual
leader kisses the child on the lips
after a few seconds he then asks the
child to suck his tongue in a statement
released on his website the Dalai Lama's
office said a video clip has been
circulating that shows a recent meeting
when a young boy asked his Holiness the
Dalai Lama if he could give him a hug
his Holiness wishes to apologize to the
boy and his family as well as his many
friends across the world for the hurt
his words may have caused his Holiness
often teases people he meets in an
innocent and playful way even in public
and before cameras he regrets the
incidents
two climate protesters have clashed with
Museum security guards after they jumped
over the barrier to a dinosaur display
footage shows just stop oil members
entering the deputy the Diplodocus
exhibit at Herbert art gallery and
museum in Coventry before guards tried
to remove them police say two people
were arrested this morning in the museum
on suspicion of conspiracy to cause
criminal damage
to Italy now where coast guards have
been trying to help around 1200 people
who are on two boats trying to reach
Europe one of the vessels with 400
people on board was reported to be
taking on water earlier today off the
coast of Malta while the other is off
Sicily and it's carrying around 800
people it's guys Adele Robinson has the
latest
in Italian Waters at a pace unmatched in
recent years a wave of Migrant Crossings
continues this one of the latest a
fishing boat with 400 on board taking on
water out of fuel and no Captain
believed to be refugees departing from
Libya but becoming adrift between Malta
and Greece according to a volunteer-run
distress hotline calls for help were
ignored with claims Maltese authorities
ordered nearby ships not to rescue the
boat only Supply fuel
you need to be an investigation of what
happened you know why fish invested that
was in Greek certain rescue area need to
arrive to the Italian search and rescue
area to be rescued this is my question
but I don't have the answer the answer
is in the hands of the governments
no response to Sky News from Maltese
authorities but finally as the boat made
its way to Italian Waters the Coast
Guard there responded and it wasn't the
only rescue this weekend with over 2 000
people picked up including 1700 refugees
reaching the island of lampedusa in 48
hours alone
dozens have lost their lives so far this
year in the Mediterranean Sea including
children after a shipwreck in February
Charities are worried about more to come
as official figures show the numbers
making Boat Crossings this year are up
nearly fourfold with an expectation this
summer may become overwhelming Adele
Robinson Sky News
York City Center Iron Age settlements in
the Shetland Isles and the merseyside
park are among seven sites being backed
by the government to be given world
heritage status it's awarded by UNESCO
to places that are considered to be of
outstanding Universal value to humanity
and which also need protection for
future Generations now if successful
they'll join 33 other UK sites including
Stonehenge and Hadrian's Wall from York
shiny Murray came reports York is a city
steeped in history with roots as a Roman
Fortress before Viking and Norman
occupation
it's historic streets and buildings tell
a story linking layers of our past to
the present day which is why it's one of
seven UK locations in the running for
UNESCO world heritage status
a mark of cultural significance that
tourists feel is well overdue
are there so many layers historical
layers in New York and they keep the
city alive for a lot of farm visitors as
well be really different it's different
to Bath it's different to London and
it's it's got a character in that
history to it that don't find elsewhere
I would say come it's very welcome in
and there's something for everybody for
Nick who runs free tours a day here
UNESCO recognition will mean Better
Business I believe that what that will
develop is bringing in more people into
the City and we are quite famous anyway
but I think if we've got unesco's site
it really shows how passionate we are
protecting our heritage and it's
cultural past and its future and
developing its future as a city not just
a tourist City you know generating
businesses that as shown in what York's
got to offer as a whole really becoming
a UNESCO world heritage site will come
with benefits for York or anywhere else
that gets the nod some are obvious like
increased publicity and tourism but the
prestigious status also gives access to
funding for its protection and
conservation
there are half a dozen other sites of
government backing including birkenhead
Park in merseyside the Marine Park of
the Cayman Islands and the Zenith of
Iron Age Shetland
a tour guide from Shetland says its
inclusion is a reminder remote locations
are historically important too we want
different types of people to come to
Chevron to come for different reasons
here's another one to come for them to
come to and in a more remote out of the
way exciting extraordinary place
whether it's York or another of the
country's Treasures one is almost
certain to become Britain's 34th UNESCO
world heritage site the rest will have
to wait a decade for the chance to come
again shinki marike Sky News York